[Music]
and chill out news till refrigerators
smooth my rocket pop cool now what's
that that's a rocket up pop dude your
childhood sucks compared to my childhood
yeah you're white dude we get it yeah
just saying you have love it has cherry
on top oh just just bought those the
other day Steve Adam oh I thought you
said rocket pastro pops bro yeah exactly
oh that's a stroke called
creamsicles a big big cig I had a
deposit box that's the hood treat bro
because you get because you would get
400 for $3 at the time and it comes out
of like a stream - it was chemicals
wrapping chemicals did I know any
chemicals with them I would have like
Funyuns with them oh my god that sounds
good you guys know the upgraded version
of a otter pop an icicle live yours had
I stole the beer line
those maniacs what are they gonna do
next yeah and then they're all slushy
yeah we smack each other on the back of
the head yeah used to take them out of
the freezer and just drink them dude no
bullies are a little bit different well
these are the I was a degenerate that's
it I put that [ __ ] and I would just
drink it like it's cool that you're a
maniac all right if people didn't like
you know sometimes you you run into kids
that that grew up a little upper class
or they're like super controlled and
they didn't eat this [ __ ] I'm hella
judgmental matter I'm just like you
didn't have that like you guys didn't
have almond butter and uh well Chris no
my parents loved me and wanted me to
have a good childhood you never bought
ice cream from a pedophile in event
you're protecting you from junk food
like [ __ ] those kids they're [ __ ]
weird anyway a new study says that being
precise can be bad for your
relationships oh really
that's me dude I'm always general I get
it was Warren just pointed part I'm very
like that and I apologize how do you
like how are you so like for me because
like I like to know things and like
figure things out when things don't
really need to be figured out like I
start to like I have to understand how
things work
you're too literal yeah so I started
like understand like things you know and
I think because of that I get really
precise but to other people it seems
like it's precise but for me I'm just
trying to seek understanding I think
that spread to our entire friend group
because I see all of us do that really
yeah we all talk that way sorry guys
Stevens do that he's awesome doesent
yeah so this study here it was published
in the Journal of Experimental
Psychology and it was examining how
pettiness can affect relationships oh
yeah pettiness I mean precise
preciseness is a bit different but
pettiness is that's how they're there
losing together their wording enough
pettiness but what we're really talking
about here is preciseness so in one
experiment they are talking about how
people were shown to transaction
histories from venmo the payment app and
in one a person paid back acquaintances
in round amounts like $10 $35 and $20
that's what I do
yeah well the other person paid $9.99
3495 and 2006 those other Tony let me
ask you this though
did they round up oh yeah see when you
cuz I round up me too sometimes or
sometimes I just do it like I just on
the dot but I will never round down
because I think that's [ __ ] up it is
example here so the last amount was 2006
which was technically 6 cents more than
what the other example was which was $20
so they did round 6 cents down right so
then they're saying that in this
situation here a lot of the participants
pick the person who paid round amounts
even though the second one they paid a
little bit extra so they're just saying
like they prefer people that it's just
like what why be you saw nitpicky was
that clear the preciseness that really
just doesn't i'm not precise as money i
don't really give a [ __ ] um I do both
yeah I do both only because it depends
in the context I'm so bad at math that
I'll just pay what somebody tells me to
pay like literally like we got lunch
yesterday and I paid Casey back from in
venmo and and Joe was like it's 1415 and
I just paid 1450 do the math of anything
cuz I literally looked at how much it
was and then I put in a calculator
divisor and that's also different
because it's easier to do that because
it's not a round a mountain that's also
different because someone's instructing
you to do that yes right but it's if
you're in your own space away from the
person or whatever you see you're like
alright well I don't wanna think about
it and it's a thank you like for like
spotting me or whatever yeah when it
comes to money I'm not very precise I
think for me when I get precise is when
I'm trying to understand a person's
mindset
me yeah mindset and behavior yes another
example here there were single people
that were shown fake dating profiles
that included a response to a question
about how long a person would help a
friend move furniture and so they're
saying that if third of the profile is
indicated that they'd help for exactly
an hour and 56 minutes from 1 p.m. to
256 p.m. sounds like my kind of friends
said that they would help for two hours
from 1 p.m. to 3 p.m. and then the other
third said that they would help for 2
hours and 4 minutes from 1 p.m. to 3 or
4 p.m. so until the job is done yeah
that's my chore that option I was like I
don't want these friends yeah so then
they're saying that even though the last
person would technically stay for 4
minutes longer because it's so precise
people were like no just pick though it
also makes that person feel so uptight
like loosen the [ __ ] oh you know because
even for like there's like people who
I'd say like their acquaintances and if
they're a decent person they asked me
for a favor I'll do it let's say like
it's moving stuff fransokyo can you help
me move I'm like man I don't really [ __ ]
what you like that but I guess I will
even then I could give him two hours
I'll still do it till the job's done
you know even if it's an acquaintance
that I just kind of like you know I mean
I think that's like the human thing to
do
use only people stranded yeah I can't
imagine like okay there's still boxes in
the chocolate thing okay I'll see you
later
like I just want to raise that well do
what we do and don't help at all
exactly just be honest because the thing
that I hate doing is I hate making the
other person feel like they're a burden
to me or rushed like I got a [ __ ]
rush out man
I'm doing this as a big [ __ ] favor
for you I hate that [ __ ] dude because
it's like don't even come if you can't
even do it fully don't even do it in the
first place that's why I don't like that
precise stuff like I understand why it's
petty you know what I mean like last
year I was a part of a wedding party and
they I told them straight up
front I'm a busy dude I'm not gonna fly
over I can't help you out with all the
stuff if you want me to stand there and
be in a suit I could do that for you
that's it [ __ ] emailed me every
[ __ ] other day about some [ __ ]
why am I gotta call him up I was like yo
well I told you this is all I can do
this whole petty thing why not this is
dumb you know I mean I just you already
told him the truth neither at home
straight up face value all I can do is
wear the monkey suit and be up there
with you that's it right you know and so
like that's the face value part is just
a smaller pace stuff why aren't you
doing this how come you not going on my
bachelor's I let you just told you I
can't do it right like what do you want
from me man you know so [ __ ] annoying
some bachelor parties I wish I never
went to at all I'm like we went to a
desert Palm Springs
there's 114 degrees damn just a little
house that was a bachelor party yeah and
I was like why the [ __ ] are we here this
is insane yeah I could be at home right
now like my eyeballs were boiling in my
head if it was if it was this group I
would have mind that situation I agree
with you we're a fun group though we are
forgiven I always say it's like the
people not the place like we could make
[ __ ] a crack alley in downtown LA be
fun that's true - am i will say
eventually I had fun but only because I
started drinking immediately to cope
with the situation with the heat of the
situation not the guys the guys were
full we're cool it was too [ __ ] hot
yeah it was just too [ __ ] hot as
crazy me and Nikki were to the same
place for our I guess our early
honeymoon because we were going to Bali
in November so we got married in May so
like we're just gonna go somewhere now I
went to Palm Springs same [ __ ] wished we
didn't go wish I had learned my lesson
it was like two weeks do you went after
it was two weeks after I had one damn
I'm a dumb [ __ ] never doubt the know you
thought the weather was gonna be
different this time it's because people
talked it up so much Palm Springs oh my
god so so the clearing a bad time on
tour any heat streak or something you
know you're right they're going your
winner yeah I mean it was nice where we
went in spring yeah we do
but like a week before that I went back
with you cats but but I already knew the
weather was gonna be tight
well while we were talking about going
to Palm Springs I'm looking that [ __ ] up
on the phone I'm off 74 Fosters now we
had a pool - yeah that we didn't use we
got to pull with the little house - but
it didn't matter it was like jumping
into boiling hot water crazy is there
any other like nitpicky research things
yourself I mean that's done I just
thought it was interesting the two
things is like time and money yeah but I
think everyone is a little OCD depending
on what they value I think that's those
are just examples but I understand what
it means in pettiness in the
relationship right so there's a lot of
the times I think that's specifically
when it comes to guys and girls I feel
like both genders have their own little
petty things that yeah yeah you know
it's it's whatever think value so like
what I what I always say no and that was
help me not fight with not to be honest
with you Mariel has done Maryland I have
gone to one huge fight in the last like
a year and a half but before it was
disaster every single black cuz we were
so [ __ ] penny one person had to be
right or the other person had to be
right or we had a nitpick why you know
sometimes like from Ariel when she's
upset and she's just like that I don't
want to ask like why are you upset
what's the reason let me try to fix it I
just need to shut the [ __ ] up and be
like it'll pass you're upset you know so
like like the other day to Mariel and
the only thing Marilee has Merrill has
to do for me now as you say hey I'm in a
shitty ass mood then I'm like got it and
I'll take a little bit of abuse and I'll
just be a little more sweet that day you
know so I had to take away that goofy
part of me away a little bit I just give
her a little more hugs and kisses I'm in
a bad mood I just don't talk so she
could talk as much she wants I could
just I think just chill just be quiet
that me - I don't say a [ __ ] word yes
so like with her she knows that I tell
it like if I'm in a bad mood though like
well I don't want to be around her I'll
let her know that was like hey today
it's not the day like today is not the
day
[Music]
[Music]